hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible attacking game from this
year's round three of the European Club
Cup for women uh it is a Greek
International Master stava atako you
guys are always welcome to correct me if
I mess up a pronunciation and I'm pretty
sure I I I have done so right now
against Armenian grandmas Elina danelon
uh it's a really crazy game where some
of the moves maybe were not engine
perfect but it's it's something that we
would expect for example tal to play so
let's check it out stava has the white
pieces and she opens with Pawn to C3
stava represents the sento C chess club
and Elina represents S as vesda data
driven lab uh so we have Pon E6 the
ainur defense against the English we've
had this conversation a couple of times
and I never know why it's called the
ainur defense doesn't matter how many
guy how many times you guys ask me in
the comments I did find one person un
Reddit said that maybe it's because you
counter the English with the French but
other than that I mean I I really
haven't found anything kind of makes
sense but it also doesn't so do with it
what you will if you if you have an
origin of this do share in the comments
for everyone to learn uh and now Knight
to F3 uh we have Knight to F6 Pawn to G3
and now Pawn to D5 transposing into the
neoc Catalin Bishop to G2 and the D
captures on C4 so okay white wants to
win back the pawn this is all been
played before Queen A4 check Knight beat
to D7 and queen captures on C4 we have
Pawn to A6 preparing B5 and queen to C2
we have Pawn to C5 now Knight to C3 and
Bishop to D6 interestingly uh one other
person a very strong gentleman that had
this position twice is none other than
Magnus Carlson with the black pieces
however against uh ding Len for example
he played Queen to C7 and he lost that
game it was the very nice game that we
covered from the singfield cup uh in uh
2019 uh but here uh we have sorry not
Queen to C7 we have B Bishop to D6 also
a move Magnus played but he played
against Neils grandelius in the Norway
Blitz tournament so let's uh see what
happened here in that game grandelius
went castles and grandelius won that
game so Magnus with this opening with
black has a loss against the ding and a
draw against Neils grandelius uh so
probably it's a very very difficult
opening to handle Pawn to D4 uh castles
by both of them and now we have C
captures on D4 Knight captures and now
Queen to C7 uh Queen to E7 was played by
hun nean against um C yugerov and hun
lost that game but here we have Queen to
C7 or maybe Neeman had the white piece I
don't know but uh all in all Neiman lost
that game so Queen to C7 it's a
different variation than Queen to E7 the
the one from the hanses game and Rook to
D1 uh and now there is a game where
Bishop to B4 was played but here we have
Rook to d8 and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game and
here we have Bishop to E3 a move that
you would uh well you probably wouldn't
play or maybe you would but uh you have
to ask yourselves uh where do you
develop the bishop you can't really put
it to F4 if you put it to G5 then uh H6
and what what is the bishop doing if
you're not ready to trade it for the
Knight you're not playing Bishop to G5
so how do you develop uh you could go
Bishop to D2 or Bishop to E3 and here
it's not the the best move you could
just uh uh attack the bishop with Knight
to G4 and once the bishop moves because
you really don't want to trade now
you're going to play Pawn to H6 but in
the game Pawn to H6 was played right
away and although it doesn't it's not
like a terrible move for black or
anything white should probably
objectively just continue developing but
here stava plays uh what can only be
described as a tall move or as a tall
series of moves she plays Bishop
captures on H6 followed immediately by
Knight captures on E6 in order to clear
the G6 Square for the queen so Bishop
captures an H6 and there really isn't a
better move you have to capture the
bishop so G captures on H6 and now
Knight captures on E6 played with tempo
as with the queen on C7 is hanging so F
captures on G6 and now Queen to G6 with
check now what's the idea be behind this
double Pawn sacrifice well let's see
King to h8 this is the strongest move
and now Rook eight to C1 now you are
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries with the Knight so this is
basically a free development uh for the
Rook here and you can use that Rook
later on maybe to attack the black uh
Kings sorry wrong Arrow uh if you can do
that then of course you are winning and
the only way for black to survive this
is to play not what was played in the
game I'm sure you guys know what to play
because you are always looking for that
right move in in difficult positions and
you always you know close your eyes and
you see banuk telling you you know the
strongest move is always with the Knight
back Knight to G8 is the way to hold
this now the the idea is that if Knights
to B5 which looks great attacks the
queen you're going to win back the piece
uh black says Nope not today Queen
captures on C1 this was the defense that
Elena had to find in order to survive
this Rook captures and C1 a captures on
B5 and now okay Queen can capture on E6
but the Knight will go to F6 attack the
queen everything is defended black is
just up to much material and black will
win the game regardless of being down a
queen and having um somewhat of a loose
King but you just have too many pieces
so after Rook eight to C1 Rook to G8 was
played but now uh it is not enough Queen
captures on H6 Knight to H7 and now
comes Knight to E4 here the move to find
again was Knight to B5 Knight to E4 is
also fine but Knight to B5 now just
doesn't work for black to give up the
queen you could go for something like
Bishop to f8 to try and give up the
queen but then Queen captures on H7 is a
beautiful s so guys it comes with check
King captures now Knight captures and C7
attacks The Rook here and once you move
the Rook Knight captures on E6 yes you
are down a piece but you are up four
pawns and one once those pawns start
marching forward uh well one extra piece
is not going to stop them so after
Knight H7 she went for Knight E4 it's a
bit of a different idea uh and now
Bishop to C5 here again Bishop to f8 is
the way to play but uh this is again
just lost queen captures King captures
Rook captures and C7 bit of a different
line Rook to G7 to help out with the
defense here Knight to D6 and okay
Bishop captures Rook captures uh Knight
to F6 you you trade Rooks Rook captures
King captures and now the Rook stops the
development of the of Black's Queen side
she will not be able to develop the
bishop and the rook and while the king
you know goes over to to chase away The
Rook you will just start advancing those
pawns and white should be much faster uh
but uh okay maybe white will not win
this but it is better for white however
after Bishop to C5 it is objectively
completely winning and she finds it
Knight captures and C5 Knight captures
and now Queen to E3 it's impossible to
defend the Knight as B6 Falls the bishop
captures on A8 it would be a freeh
hanging Rook uh but we have Queen to G7
trying to go for some counterplay here
Rook captures on C5 and now Knight to F6
okay if you can develop your pieces you
you can maybe get back into the game H
but stula will not allow it Rook to D4
Now The Rook is coming to H4 of course
and we are uh reaching uh that position
from the thumbnail uh Queen to E7 now
comes Queen to H6 with check the Knight
blocks you could block with the queen
but then of course the Knight hangs and
you just get checkmated so Knight has
the block and now Rook to H5 and now
Rook to H4 and the bishop to E4 are
coming and this is just a massacre Rook
to A7 preparing B5 so The Rook joins the
defense of the of the black king Rook D
to H4 we have Rook to G7 and now Bishop
to E4 going after the Knight Here pawn
to B6 now everything is defending here
look at this the the queen double Rook
battery attacking H7 and The Rook Queen
Rook defending on H7 and also the bishop
is here to to help out with the action
and the like in the previous two games
that we've covered our good friend the
light Square Bishop just you know
enjoying the show not really being a
part of the game that's just the you
know that's the uh the way it often is
with your light Square Bishop so you
know uh learning openings and you know
studying opening theory is basically uh
learning how to develop your light
Square Bishop with black that's pretty
much it so here we have Bishop captures
on H7 uh there are other moves you could
play but Bishop captures on H7 is the
most straightforward way to win Rook
captures and queen to G6 now leaving um
Elina without a single move if you
capture then just Rook captures and you
have to give up the queen uh you can
even play uh Queen T8 with check to pick
up the bishop doesn't really matter
captures captures you're going to take
the bishop and the queen of course will
defeat the lonely Rook so after Queen to
G6 she tried one last trick and it's
actually a good trick if it works Queen
captures on H4 Rook captures on H4 and
now Rook captures on H4 if um stava goes
for the automatic G captures an H4 then
Rook G7 picks up the queen and now it
will be problematic for white to to
solve this being down a full piece
however she played Queen to F6 with
check and it was in this position on
move 31 that Alina danelon resigned the
game uh as there is nothing more to be
done here of course once the king moves
or you block with the Rook doesn't
really matter you will pick up the Rook
uh you can also pick it up with the pawn
but I guess I mean why why would you
ruin your Pawn structure you capture
with the queen and the queen will over
power the bishop and The Rook uh because
you are also up three pawns so you know
you you can also just push the pawns and
you're going to win the game uh so after
Queen to F6 she resigned and a wonderful
wonderful victory for Greek
International master stava soloko and I
don't know how their team played but I
can check if you guys are interested let
me just quickly check uh okay so they of
course um do not have six players like
in the men section they have um four
players per team uh and the match ended
two uh 22 so it was a it was a draw uh
but definitely a great win on board one
and what a what a game so sometimes it's
uh you know it's better to not go for
the uh for the uh move that you kind of
think that objectively should be played
Rook a to C1 because I mean you're
playing a classical game it's a serious
game of course if if you don't play Rook
eight to C1 your teammates will just uh
you know look at you weirdly for the
entire game and then you play Bishop
captures an H6 and then I'm pretty sure
the entire H you know all the players on
all the boards come over to see what's
happening when they see Bishop captures
on H6 and Knight captures on E6 and
they're probably like wow I wish this
was my game uh but it's not uh so yeah
there we have it very nicely done by
stava uh thank you very much for
suggesting such a such a nice game I
would like to thank Robert arathun Das
Kumar K Ingram Bernard Rani and Mr
hoodie guy for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day